ملقون على جنبات شوارع السودان منكبون على
ظهورهم او بطونهم لا فرق
هذا احد تقاطعات حي الحلفايه يلفظ جثثا
مرميه على الاطراف
لايام وما زالت اجسادهم تربك الطرقات
يمشون بجانبها متجاهلين ان انفاسها انقطعت
وبل من القصف يعرقل سبل نقل رفاتهم فالحي
منهم لا يجرؤ على الذهاب بجثامينهم الى
المشرحه لتكدوسها وايضا خشيه ان ترضيه
رصاصه ظلت طريقها اليه فلا هدنه تفي
بالحياه
[موسيقى]
من هنا تنبعث رائحه موت اخر تفوح منه ازمه
صحيه وبيئيه ففي مستشفى الساحه مثلا يتجمع
الجرح من قوه الدعم السريع لكن الكادر
الطبي يعجز عن معالجه الاعداد المتزايده
من الاصابات استمرار نزف احدهم يشيء
بزياده عدد القتلى وتضاف اليه عباره
كارثيه لا متسعه لمزيد من الجثث في مشارح
الخرطوم التي تكابد اعدادهم لثلاث سنوات
فمنها جثث تعفنت واخرى تحللت اما عن
رائحتها فحدث ولا حرج
مخلفات الحرب تهدد السودان وتضعه في
تحديات معقده فهناك نفايات بالاقوام
تتكاثر فيها فرص انتشار الامراض المعديه
والجرثوميه لتكاثر الحشرات والذباب حولها
وانبعاث الروائح الكريهه هي المصائب هكذا
لا تاتي فرادى على السودان حرب دروس محمله
بازمتين صحيه وبيئيه اسراء الصغير العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات